bonsoir comme dit patrick isana qui est
un très bon comédien
on al impression lorsque vous vous
parlez que vous former qu'une seule et
même personne alors comment vous allez
et comment vous avez travaillé sept
cette comédie cette pièce on a beaucoup
travaillé on travaille beaucoup on est
des gros travailleur ans n'est pas
peut-être tellement doué mais un travail
beaucoup beaucoup et on travaille
tellement que ça se voit pas on voit pas
qu'on a travaillé mais on a beaucoup
travaillé on travaille beaucoup
alors comment on a travaillé dans un ça
a été c'est miraculeux
moi je peux le dire parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup de j'ai joué dans une
quarantaine de pièces mais c'est
miraculeux il s'est passé quelque chose
de miraculeux
ça tient à quoi je ne sais pas ça tient
peut-être je sais pas une simplicité à
un dépouillement
ça a été un bonheur tout le temps les
mots sont légers ils nous font rire on
rit beaucoup et puis on n'est pas loin
des larmes et de l'émotion un moment
vous avez été surpris par les premières
réactions du public
oui on était oui à ce point là on
s'imaginait pas qu'ils allaient rire
autant mais c'est vrai qu'il a une une
écriture qui vient qui vient vraiment du
coeur une écriture avec un rythme un
rythme naturel rythme quand on prend
tous est une vraie logique interne qui
ne peut que nous atteindre parce que sur
qu'un frère c'est s'inquiète guère le
symbole du quai de gare c'est quoi ces
symboles du temps qui passe et se
vendent eux tout est possible toutes les
rencontres sont possibles comment vous
interprétez le cas de guerre vous l'un
puis l'autre ou l'une puis l'autre
d'abord c'est un lieu théâtral parce que
en haletant parce que ces dépouilles et
parce qu'il ya une poésie quand même de
la gare 20 quai de gare il ya une
certaine poésie c'est un univers qui est
je pense très un beau cadre de théâtre
on peut rarement imaginer un cadre aussi
dépouillé aussi simple aussi à quelques
fois ces sinistres les quatre quarts non
vous n'êtes jamais ennuyé sur un quai de
gare
oui il ya l'ennui il ya le départ qui
est qui qui peut être douloureux ça peut
être aussi des retrouvailles c'est aussi
les trains pendant la guerre c'est sait
beaucoup de choses il ya aussi un état
c'est vrai qu'à la tente du tram il ya
aussi l'état d'urgence il ya un moment
quelqu'un qui va partir c'est une pièce
sur l'amour qu'est ce que vous aimez
chez lui par la wii je trouve tes c'est
parce que dans le team caisse en tout
cas 20 personnages cultes après il est
quand même possessif
il est très présent presque trop
présente pour une fille non bailly sont
heureux ensemble ils sont il devient il
devient il devient généreux après c'est
celle pas que doit faire tous les
parents pour arriver à lâcher leurs
enfants alors nous on est un peu vieux
on importe mais c'est c'est tout le
chemin qu'on a à faire pour accepter de
voir ses enfants heureux sens en soi
avec avec d'autres qu'est ce que vous
aimez cheveux pour boisset marie c'est
celle à merveille jamais rien eu avec
elle de qui marchait pas depuis qu'elle
est toute petite depuis qu'elle est née
même je crois que petite elle a jamais
pleuré je sais pas je me souviens pas
que qu'elle ait été un moment un
problème souci elle a été que du bonheur
tout le temps et c'est pour ça que non
seulement vous jouer cette pièce la
commission accc est gars mais vous avez
aussi les poèmes à lou si vous êtes
décidé de travailler maintenant toujours
tous les deux ont peut-être pas toujours
mais oui c'est vrai que la dernière fois
qu'on était au théâtre
c'était il ya un an et demi en juin saad
il ya une phrase qui a été qui a été
coupée d'ailleurs dans la pièce mais qui
qui résume assez bien le rapport jeudi à
un moment secret va élever des filles
pour 80 ans et vous
elle s'appelle vous quitte avec le
premier mec venue alors c'est beaucoup
vous allez me dire la halle cicero pas
vous tous et je voyais juste avant
journal vous tous et vous détestez vivre
à paris parce que c'est polluer vous
êtes un petit peu misanthrope
non vous vivez à petit on retrouve pas
du tout non j'aime bien les gens non
j'aime beaucoup les gens contrat je suis
très curieux non les gens m'aiment
m'intéresse beaucoup alors comme je suis
très timide je peux pas leur parler mais
j'aimerais beaucoup vous êtes transmis
votre timidité à votre fille et pourtant
vous faites du théâtre store quelque
chose qui me surprend surtout vous là
dans cette pièce zagoritis cette
capacité de dire les choses avec
légèreté mais avec une totale impudeur
tout compte fait sur le théâtre
comment vous basculez de là un autre sur
une scène de théâtre on a vraiment une
une sensation de liberté on al'excuse
que c'est pas nouveau
ces panneaux fra/sau c'est des phrases
qui ont été écrits et la sensation
personne ne nous arrêtera donc ça donne
une espèce de de liberté pour les
timides et on peut insulter les insultes
et la vie les gens et être en même temps
irresponsable et sincère sur moment
et puis le fait de pas être arrêté non
j'aime beaucoup
ouais ça doit pas être facile pour
patrick lisala de travailler entre vous
deux je suis maître entre vous deux vous
laisser un peu d'espacé à quelqu'un
entre vous qu'on leur met dans la vie en
bout relation patrick c'est une
merveilleuse un garçon formidable non
l'aiment beaucoup je pense qu'il est
heureux avec nous
non je pense qu'il est heureux ne vous
ai pas l'impression vous formez
tellement un duo y compris dans la vie
que c'est de pas être évident de de
rentrer dans votre univers
si les gens figure c'est un deuxième
volet sort de la pièce alors bon nous
mettons en situation et jeu il joue dans
la villa il a les rapports qu'il a au
théâtre avec nous mais c'est vraiment un
camarade magnifique d'abord je trouve
formidable comme comédien et il est il
est très agréable en plus il a ce qu'il
faut de tendresse
il est mystérieux ça c'est bien ce trou
alors on a le plaisir de votre vos
serrures au théâtre vous avez décidé que
le cinéma c'était fini vous vous
continuez le ciné max et c'est une
divergence une différence entre vous il
ne peut pas y dit qu'il arrête au pas me
piquer mes rôles parce que vous on va
vous voir par exemple harrison's flowers
un rôle d'homme le film d'elie chouraqui
tf1 continue cinéma et vous dites je
préfère me consacrer au théâtre parce
que yann un rapport au public quelque
chose de plus vrai mais c'est un choix
j'ai fait beaucoup cinéma toute ma vie
plus que de théâtre et maintenant j'ai
envie de faire uniquement du théâtre si
j'avais beaucoup de temps si on m'assure
est encore 50 ans je vais peut-être me
cinéma mais là je crois que j'aurais
plus 50 ans et vous qui êtes obsédé par
temps qui passe cette pièce là vous
donne quand même un peu d'optimisme une
passe que la fin de la pièce donne aussi
une sorte de mini miss mme c'est ce qui
est très extraordinaire dans cette
chaîne je crois que c'est vraiment un
événement ça va être un des événements
je pense de du théâtre de c'est
peut-être de cette décennie
c'est que ans c'est une pièce qui parle
de choses finalement très grave sans en
avoir l'air voilà où on rit beaucoup et
ça parle de des choses essentielles de
la vie
merci beaucoup en tout cas parce que on
a passé un vrai moment magique grâce à
vous notre sort théâtre hébertot v et
merci surtout d'être venu parce que je
sais que la représentation avec un peu
décalé pour ce soir vers son gmt à
travers tout jusqu'à mi avril
c'est ça oui mais peut-être que le ps
continuera ensemble mais continue à la
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu voilà nous arrivons au sein de
cette édition jeu